hi ladies I brought the Baker's for the
book club this afternoon of course he
did Morgan I hope you bring your famous
blueberry muffins for the bake sale on
Thursday horse I am but I'm gonna do
them as cranberry because blueberries
are out of season and I don't need
pesticides and all those kids fine so
ladies I'm looking for volunteers bring
juice boxes for the carwash fundraiser
oh I'll bring some raw milk to your hand
seed smoothies much healthier no sugar
sounds disgusting I'm going to transcend
that comment right now I've been meaning
to tell you guys this morning a racket
said he didn't want a nurse I think he's
weaning I don't think I'm ready for it
there's an arachnid in third grade yeah
you know what though I have done a ton
of research on breastfeeding and
actually in most countries it is totally
common for moms not to lean until six
seven years old
I'm gonna send you guys all a link to
dr. Sears his website because every
parent should read what yes oh god we
don't have a computer
no we got our typewriter it's just
really important to us that she's raised
strictly authentic but she's only listen
to vinyl
none of that mp3 processed stuff yeah
I'm here what do you say oh my god look
like you like I'm here I'm here
wait is it Tuesdays at soccer practice
no book club oh wow cuz I my day to
bring the bagels no no I put the bagel
oh thank you uh but you have signed our
shirts boop boop or chocolate pooper
chocolate no no no's chocolate sync God
last time is poop
oh good protein though you know what
Karen you're a real [ __ ] for bringing
those bagels we knew I was gonna forget
them it's not my fault that your child
can't eat gluten